let's go to five headlines
[Music]
the dnc was last night uh i said
yesterday that i'd rather stick my face
in a
blender than watch it but fortunately my
blender wasn't working well actually i
got the blender working last night so i
was able to do that
instead blended the old face um you
can't tell the difference though
due to the fact that i'm uh hideous
you know but anyway i uh i didn't watch
the dnc
i don't care about it though there are
two clips from the proceedings that i
saw that
maybe are are worth playing and
responding to we'll save the second one
the most important one
for the last on the list on the five
headlines but
first one we'll play this this is uh
michelle obama speaking at the dnc and
here's what she had to say
and here at home as george floyd
brianna taylor and a never-ending list
of
innocent people of color continue to be
murdered stating the simple fact that a
black life
matters is still met with derision
from the nation's highest office
because whenever we look to this white
house for some leadership
or consolation or any semblance of
steadiness
what we get instead is chaos division
and a total and utter lack of empathy
empathy that's something i've been
thinking a lot about lately
now you know i actually agree with her
that the white house hasn't done nearly
enough to address the chaos
as i was just talking about but i'm
quite sure that she would not like
my idea for addressing the chaos i agree
i agree there's too much chaos
more needs to be done uh but i don't
think that she'd be in favor of sending
in the military for example which is
what should be done
as for the rest of it she says that
black people continue to be murdered
i agree with that also and i agree with
a lot of this she's absolutely right
black people
are murdered every day they are murdered
at a far more than any other group
they are at a much higher risk of being
victims both of murder and other violent
crimes all of that is true but the thing
that michelle obama doesn't mention and
that no other democrat will ever mention
is that the vast
vast overwhelming majority of black
people who are murdered
are murdered by members of their own
race that's the reality
um we can point this out all we want and
they'll ignore it
i realize that even so it must be
continually pointed out we can't tire of
meeting these false narratives because
if we do then there's no hope then
the narrative wins and that's the end of
it because the people on the left
who claim to be concerned about black
victims as we discovered are really only
concerned about a highly specific and
limited little sliver of the overall
victim category
and you know that's the case for
michelle obama but let's go to number
two
to the opposite of michelle obama here's
someone who really is concerned with
black life all black life
kim klasik congressional nominee in
baltimore
she put out an ad yesterday that that i
think is really spectacular and it gives
a blueprint
okay the point here is not just that
it's a great ad which it is but
this is other republicans need to look
at this
see it as a blueprint this is how to
deal with these sorts of issues watch
[Music]
do you care about black lives the people
that run baltimore don't
i can prove it walk with me they don't
want you to see this
[Music]
i'm kim klasik this is baltimore the
real baltimore
this is a reality for black people every
single day
crumbling infrastructure abandoned homes
poverty
and crime baltimore has been run by the
democrat party for 53 years
what is the result of their decades of
leadership
baltimore is one of the top five most
dangerous cities in america
the murder rate in baltimore is 10 times
the u.s average the baltimore poverty
rate is over 20 percent
homicide drug and alcohol deaths are
skyrocketing in our city
do you believe black lives matter i do
the vast majority of crime in baltimore
is perpetrated against black people
who make up 60 of the population so why
don't we care about our communities
the democrat party have betrayed the
black people of baltimore
if the politicians walk the streets like
i do they would see exactly how their
policies and corruption
affects us if they don't want to see it
they don't want you to see this yeah um
as i said great ad and this is a you
know the proof is in the pudding and
this is sort of a
showing the pudding type of situation um
because the reality is
ass has been pointed out many times but
you know
it's it's it's fine to point it out that
can only go so far
sometimes you have to show instead of
tell and that's what she's doing here
these cities that have been run by
democrats for decades
are in shambles that's and
when i say shambles like literally you
look at those
you look at those images and what you're
seeing there
you know someone who's lived around
baltimore i lived in the baltimore area
myself for many years i didn't live in
the inner city
but um i've been in the city many times
i've driven through it
uh and i can tell you for with my own
eyes that
what you saw there is not even the worst
parts of baltimore and i assume because
in the very
very worst parts it wouldn't be smart
for her to you know
walk around uh it wouldn't be safe so
that's like a few steps up from the
worst parts of baltimore that you saw
right there and it's
really really bad um to put it to put it
very mildly
and that's a a simple reality
baltimore's one example you see other
examples all across the country
chicago detroit uh even new york now
is and it's getting worse there
so this is all you have to do is show it
that this is what happens with democrat
policies
now let's go um all right speak a lot of
great transitions here okay it's all
it's all
flowing very smoothly speaking of bad
democrat policies we go to andrew cuomo
who directly responsible for the deaths
of thousands of elderly people
intentionally exposed them to the virus
by sending infected patients into
nursing homes
that andrew cuomo just to be specific is
writing a book about
his response to the coronavirus okay
uh the just the gumption of this guy
the book is called american crisis let
me pull up the
press release it says crown an imprint
of random house publishing
uh announced today that the it will
publish american crisis by andrew cuomo
on october 13th 2020
a revealing behind the scenes account of
his experience leading new york through
the covet 19 epidemic
american crisis is an important
chronicle of this unprecedented moment
in history
an urgent assessment of the factors that
have and continue to impede
our national response to a devastating
health and economic catastrophe uh you
know a couple questions come up right
away first of all
how do you have time to write a book
right now you're currently governor
this is usually a thing you do after
you've left office
uh after cuomo has mercifully been voted
out
which you know the people of new york
i'm not sure if they're smart enough to
actually vote him out
but because he's still relatively
popular there even though he doesn't
deserve to be
but after you leave you write the book
reflect he's writing it while he's so
he's
he's talking about how he's he's
handling the pandemic he's in the middle
of all of this
but he's got time to write a book uh and
then of course on top of all that it's
the fact that he again
is directly responsible for killing
thousands of elderly people
i wonder if that's going to get a
chapter in the book that's the chapter i
would like to read and that's the story
that's the story that i would like to
hear about
the chapter on when he murdered i don't
know if it'll be you know chapter five
when i murdered a bunch of elderly
people i don't know how he's gonna
phrase it but that's that's that's
that's the real story from this that we
all need to
hear about um number four yesterday
president trump announced
there'd be a huge pardon of a really
important person so he made this
announcement yesterday
he said someone really important is
gonna be pardoned uh lots of people were
specula
speculating very excited who's it gonna
be uh will it be joe exotic
there was there was that speculation on
the internet or you know it could have
been someone who actually deserved to be
pardoned because joe exotic does not
deserve to be
um and then today the big announcement
was made about who's getting the pardon
and here is donald trump announcing it
i wanted to just add something because
this was brought up a week ago
and i was so surprised that it was never
done before
because later today i will be signing a
full
and complete pardon for susan b
anthony she was never pardoned
did you know that she was never pardoned
what took so long and
you know that she got a pardon for a lot
of other women
and she didn't put her name on the list
so she was never
pardoned and we're for voting that's
right
that's right she was guilty for voting
and uh we are going to be signing a full
and complete pardon and i think that's
really fantastic right
that is that's great i got to tell you
uh because and it's good that he really
came through because the thing is
you wouldn't want to announce and make a
big deal out of the fact that you're
pardoning someone
uh especially when there are a lot of
people out there who really do
you know currently living and are maybe
in jail or something
and really do need the pardon so you
wouldn't want to announce that
and then do for example some really
silly pointless symbolic pardon of
someone who's already dead
you wouldn't want to do that so i'm glad
that he didn't do that in this case uh
susan b anthony
is she's been in prison for far too long
for this crime
uh and uh and so i'm glad that she'll
finally be free
and she can look return to her family
and try to reclaim some kind of life
so i i you know say congrats to mrs
anthony on that and um
you know good luck good luck of
restarting your life again and i just i
just think this is great just
uh really really long long overdue all
right
number five finally now now we get to
what really matters okay the only
important subject of this show to be
honest with you and certainly the most
notable event of the dnc convention last
night which is not a high bar to clear
but
there you have it uh this happened
apparently towards the end or at the
very end maybe
to wrap things up at the end of the
convention fortunately then for the dnc
most people had fallen asleep by the
time that this
[Music]
happened
[Music]
there's something happening here
[Music]
there's
[Music]
look what's going down
[Music]
yeah i don't i don't know
what that was or
why what why how
you know well i can figure out the how
the house but but the what and why is
really
the democrat party is seen as the party
that has people
working for it who who know how to
connect with the youth of today
and they really should have involved
some of those people in planning their
convention
because that i don't know who that's
supposed to appeal to appeal to
uh i suppose it appealed to the dude in
the video billy porter
who's an actor or something not really
sure what he does i know that he wears
dresses to the oscars that's sort of his
main thing that's what he does for a
living
and then he might have a couple side
gigs as well but when i see that i tell
you what when i see that
it brings to mind something i've been
thinking for a while which is that
liberals are kind of and this is going
to sound weird but
liberals are are kind of going the way
of
christian rock christian movies
christian entertainment
i don't mean that it's the same sort of
content okay what you just saw there you
probably wouldn't see that in a
christian
music video but they're making the same
mistake that christian entertainment and
the indus christian entertainment
industry has made
uh in that what they're doing is they're
starting to think that a piece of
entertainment
is good as long as it has the right
message
the christian entertainment industry has
been doing this forever
they put out absolutely atrocious
material
uh but horrible production quality if
it's a movie
horrible script terrible acting a lot of
really bad music
okay but they say well it's fine it's
good because it gets the message across
and there's an audience out there for it
it's not it's not as big of an audience
as what they could get
but um there's a certain audience that
uh all they care about is if it has a
christian message i like it
even if it's terrible quality i still
like it so um
but for a long time what made liberal
messaging so effective
in entertainment anyway is that they
actually prioritized artistic quality
and entertainment value
over the message they still had the
message they would get the message in
there more subtly
but the vehicle for it was a lot
sturdier because they were actually
paying attention to creating a sturdy
vehicle recently though it seems like
they're going the other way
they're putting out movies songs stuff
like this
that's cringy and bad and weird
and not good but it has a message and so
we're supposed to like it
so they're i think they're making a very
similar
kind of mistake which you know i guess
if you're not a liberal it's good to see
them
tripping up in this way um good to have
some company it's good that
conservatives aren't the only ones
making this mistake finally
let's go in fact actually i was going to
go to the daily cancellation but before
we do there's one other thing a bonus
story we'll go to number six here
um i just wanted to play this for you
because i just saw it right before we
we started shooting here uh alexandria
ocasio-cortez
is planning uh some sort of movement to
help the post office because for some
reason we have to prop up the post
i don't know why you know no no one is
is out there trying to figure out a way
to keep uh
you know companies that sell record
players afloat okay
no one's worried radio shack went under
because all they did was sell walkmans
and boom boxes
nobody was worried about keeping them up
but for some reason we got to make sure
that we keep the post office the reason
why the post office
is suffering is that a lot of people
aren't using it anymore because we have
more efficient and effective ways of
communicating
but now all of a sudden the uh the left
has decided that we got to keep them
going and this is
alexandria cortez's idea for keeping the
post office alive
listen i have been thinking about
ways to help you help
the post office and i think i've got
an idea and i'm interested in hearing
your thoughts
so one of the best ways to support the
post office
is to buy stamps what do you all think
would you guys be down and excited
if i set up a national progressive pen
pal program
do all the work of connecting you to
somebody else
we would offer maybe some conversation
prompts or postcard prompts
and even like a printable postcard
format you just
send it out would you guys be down do
you like that idea
a national progressive pen pal
program speak this is what i'm talking
about speaking of not
being able to connect with the youth
alex this is her supposed to be her
thing
aoc this is what she's supposed to do
and this is what she comes up with a
national progressive
pen pal program that's like an idea that
like my aunt would come up with right
it's it's like it's like
your grandmother let's have a pen pal
program
uh but i'm actually really annoyed at uh
amanda president the daily wire another
writer of the daily wire
because she she had an angle on this
that i wish i had thought of and it
really annoys me
but she tweeted is this good for the
environment which which is a really
really good basic point here but you
how does this help how does the post
office help the environment
where you could okay you want to send a
letter to someone you can just email it
you know and get it there at the speed
of light but instead we want to have a
you know a car a vehicle with fossil
fuels
driving it to the post office you put it
on a plane depending on where you're
mailing it to
think of all the fuel and all the co2
and how many polar bears we're killing
and but that's that's okay i mean we got
11 years we're gonna we're all going to
be dead in 11 years
and aoc wants to speed up the process so
that we can be pen
pals really all right
um great great idea there let's go to
our daily cancellation
before we do i want to tell you about
our most exclusive membership tier over
at the daily wire all access all access
members get to join all access live
our exclusive live stream discussions
hosted every night by each of the hosts
including my
myself um this thursday august 20th
we'll be doing a very special live
stream
uh like a watch party a live stream
for the democrat national convention's
biggest speakers hosted by
none other than i matt walsh i've been
i've been spending all day talking about
how boring and stupid the dnc is and how
relevant it is um
but i'm going to be hosting the watch
party because i'm the guy you want
just so i could tell you the entire time
how utterly pointless it is what we're
doing but that's that's really my thing
i guess you know
um the stream starts at 8 45 so don't
miss the big opportunity to tune in and
mock i mean watch
the final night of the dnc with me so
i'm going to be watching this whole
thing is that the idea
oh my god anyway it's going to be a lot
of fun
so head over to dailywire.com walsh
right now to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
uh that's dailywire.com walsh what did i
agree to this i don't know why i agreed
they asked me
they did ask me i'll be fair they did
say did you want to do and i said
yeah i don't know why i don't know what
i was thinking
[Music]
dailywire.com walsh with coupon code
walsh to get 20
off your membership how long is it is it
like two hours
two or three hours hey you uh
yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated